the world of frozen is actually composed
of places from around the world
the chapel is based on saint olaf's
church in norway while elsa's ice palace
might seem like a fantasy place
it's actually inspired by a real hotel
in quebec city canada called hotel de
glace
the queen's palace in snow white was fit
for royalty it was actually based on the
alcazar of segovia
a castle in spain that royalty lived in
for hundreds of years
the sultan's palace in aladdin is
extraordinary but what's even better is
the fact that a place
just as regal actually exists the taj
mahal in india was the inspiration and
it's actually one of the new seven
wonders of the world
the emperor's homa mulan is modeled
after the home of actual emperors from
the ming and qing dynasties
it's known as the forbidden city because
no one was allowed to enter or leave
without permission of the emperor
the bustling game central station in
wreck-it ralph is pretty recognizable to
any new yorker
the animators drew inspiration from
grand central station an iconic nyc spot